- He rolled into our lives with dimples
and a wrestling singlet, yeah he did.
Over 30 years ago in "Saved By The Bell",
you can see him now on "Access Hollywood"
as well as in the new
"Saved By The Bell" reboot,
coming to Peacock, please
welcome Mario Lopez!
(jazzy music)
(audience clapping)
Sorry we have to sit so far apart.
I have one bone to pick with you.
- Okay.
- So like,
with "Saved By The Bell" reboot,
I know that somebody had
to sing the theme song.
- Yes.
- Yeah, who was that?
- You know what, we
actually had Lil Yachty.
- Okay, fine. That's fine.
(laughing)
- Can I tell you something Kelly though?
- I would have totally done it.
- Okay.
- I just sang the whole thing
before you came out here with Jesse.
- I was hearing you backstage.
- Okay.
- You know I love you, you
know you're my favorite.
- I'm just saying, it
would have been amazing.
- I know you would have killed it.
- Lil Yachty's probably amazing.
- I always tell everyone 'cause you know,
first of all, thank you so
much for filling in for me
on my radio show, we did the countdown.
Everyone over at "On
With Mario" loves you.
You know, we're big, big fans.
But I always say, I feel
sorry for the other artists
when you do the Kellyoke's,
'cause you do their songs so much better.
- Oh, you're-
- I'm not lying.
You usually take it next
level and it's so much better.
Oh my God, I would by that one.
- Sometimes it doesn't work.
My favorite thing that
someone's ever said to me,
Garth was actually, Garth
Brooks was on the show
and he goes, "Is there any song,
"like any genre you wouldn't go near?"
And I was like, "There are
genres I shouldn't go near."
But I do it.
- No, no, you're killin' 'em all.
- I love music.
- I know.
- So that's what's cool about your job too
you get to like, celebrate all music.
- Yes, I love music too.
I love music, I love entertainment
that's why I love doing
"Access Hollywood".
- How has it been? Because COVID's weird.
So how's it been doing the radio show,
"Access Hollywood", all of it?
- You know what?
We really haven't stopped, to be honest.
So we did a little bit at home.
I was shooting out in my
backyard with "Access Hollywood".
- I had to do it out of my
backyard for a while too.
- Yeah, for a little while,
but then we were the first
show, I believe, on the lot,
back with "Access", which is great.
Which is nice,
because we're celebrating
our 25 year anniversary
- Wow!
- And we're really excited
over there about that.
And then, "On With Mario", with the show,
we do it on the lot as well
so everything's sort of
consolidated right here,
so we've kind of kept on going.
Between that, and then I
did my Christmas movie,
"Feliz Navidad"
- Yes, that's amazing.
- over in Nevada, so I've
been keeping really busy.
And the new "Saved By The Bell", so yeah.
- That's amazing.